[Music]
I'd like to ask the Jeff Bezos to come
out on stage so that I can speak to
indirectly mr. bule's available
thank you will he be here in this speech
I assume so we're in the middle of a
climate emergency and I think the very
least that I or other people can do is
to try to use our positions working at
it one of the most powerful companies in
the world
[Music]
[Music]
how do we tell our children that we knew
we had such a small window to act
decisively to leave fossil fuels in the
ground but instead we help Shell BP and
others find and extract oil more
listening to Emily's speech to Jeff
Bezos and the shareholder resolution
literally gave me tingles and you look
around the room and you see hey I'm with
50 other co-workers who are all standing
and all supporting her we're
representing nearly 8,000 of our other
co-workers who are really representing
all of humanity some people had said
they were considering leaving Amazon
that they felt that morally conflicted
but knowing that there was this
happening that they could get involved
made them excited to come to work I
definitely have no fear of retaliation
you want to be on the right side of
history thank you
[Applause]